- So you're doing A League of Their Own.
- [D'Arcy] Yeah.
- This is amazing.
It's on Prime Video.
So were you so excited to do it?
- So excited.
One of my favorite movies.
I grew up playing baseball and
- [Kelly] Oh, you did?
- Yeah.
- [Kelly] That's awesome.
And you know, it's like
baseball and acting
and it just was too good to be true.
- So how is it different from the movie or
is it different?
- [D'Arcy] It is different,
yeah. It's different.
I mean, you know, the movie is perfect.
It's one of my faves.
I know people feel very strongly about it,
but it was made 30 years ago.
- What? Oh, I'm old.
- [D'Arcy] Is that right?
Yeah, that's right 30 years ago.
- That's all I just heard.
- I know, I'm sorry to say that.
- Oh
- I was like 20, no, 30, 30.
- Wow.
- And they had two hours to,
you know, make this movie,
or to tell the story.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- Not, they didn't have,
they had a little more than two hours
to make the movie actually.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- Which is just like a small fact
- [Kelly] They took time.
- that I know.
But we have eight hours
and it's, you know, 2022.
So, we get into the stories
that weren't told back then.
That were really going on.
Some of the queer stories.
And you know, there's a
scene, this amazing scene,
where a woman picks, this
black woman picks up a ball
and throws it,
and she has this great arm and we see her
and then we never see her again.
- [Kelly] Yep.
- And we get to follow her.
We get to see, you know,
- [Kelly] I love that.
- her full story.
And it's just incredible.
I really am proud to
be a part of this show.
- And you're right
though. It is just a bit,
so you only get so long
and all those characters
to delve into them is really magical.
- [D'Arcy] Yeah. We really
get to, like, shine a light
on the stories that we
didn't get to see before.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- [D'Arcy] That we haven't gotten to see.
- [Kelly] And you played baseball,
you played many sports, like growing up.
- Yeah. I didn't.
My, I played baseball and basketball
but my main sport was water polo.
Why am I looking at you?
- Really?
- Yeah. Just in case you're impressed.
- [Kelly] All that,
all that just let know,
- [Lester] It's a
Northern California thing.
- is that you had money.
- Money. No. I think it was
- Cause no one played
water polo where I'm from.
- [D'Arcy] No, no I think it's
- I don't even know what water polo was.
- [D'Arcy] Right. All right.
It does sound like, I
think you think it sounds
like a rich person sport because polo
with the horses is that,
- Anything involving horses
usually involves money.
- This is not horses. There
are no horses in the pool.
- [Kelly] Oh yeah obviously.
- This is like
- [Kelly] I dunno if I know
what water polo is. What's water polo?
- [D'Arcy] I know. A lot of people don't.
- It's kind of like
soccer in a pool, but with your hands.
That's what it is.
- That's hard.
- Yeah. It is hard.
- Soccer in general is hard enough.
You had to make it worse with water.
- [D'Arcy] I know, I know.
We're treading water the whole time.
You can't touch the ground.
- [Lester] Oh my goodness.
- I'm gonna say no.
- [D'Arcy] I know.
- To that magic and fun.
- Yep.
- [Kelly] Oh my gosh.
So there are LGBTQ stories in the series,
and they're pretty important, right?
- [D'Arcy] Yeah.
- To the storylines.
- [D'Arcy] For sure, yeah.
Yeah. A lot, a lot,
a lot of storylines, not just one.
- [Kelly] Oh, that's great.
- Yeah. It's great.
It's really great.
- I, I love that.
- [D'Arcy] Yeah.
- So it's not like the token story.
People feel like, you
know, I hate to say that,
- [D'Arcy] No, but I mean, it happens
- But it's cool
- [D'Arcy] all the time.
- Yeah.
- [D'Arcy] A lot of things
that we see in media,
we get to see like just a
little piece of a story,
but we really, we really get into it.
All different kinds of stories.
- [Kelly] I love that.
- I love it too.
I'm really proud of it.
I think people are, it's
connecting with people where,
you know, social media, you
know, it's good and bad,
[D'Arcy] but when the show
came out, it just was, it was
we got such a nice
response on social media.
It was really lovely and
touching and the cast
is sending each other
screenshots and you know, it's
it's an amazing thing if,
you know, to see a tweet
that says something like,
I watched this show with
my mom and it helped her
understand me more.
And I mean, that type of stuff, it's like
you can't even that's, it's like,
it's not why one would get into acting,
because you can't even imagine it.
But to have something
like that happen is such
like icing on the cake it's really
- [Kelly] But to move
people and to connect.
- [D'Arcy] Exactly. Yeah.
- And to show empathy,
compassion, all those things,
that's what art is about.
- [D'Arcy] Yeah.
Yeah. For sure.
- Congratulations on such an awesome role.